all right it's a long time coming for a
few people yeah okay you
who's been commenting attempt to get
jeremy to review sam raimi spider-man
number 56 or whatever
here you go you got it also proof i read
comments
and also this provides reason and method
to madness first of all thank you for
the concern for my well-being after my
last
video drinking fine robe fine looking
like this
kind of fine all three together don't do
that you're gonna scare the fans but in
my defense
i was actually going to do a video on
sam raimi's spider-man
for my previous video and then i was
like oh power pill or whatever i should
probably watch that and review that and
so there you go if you were going to do
a video on remy spider-man
and you had to watch and review a pretty
mediocre movie you'd probably look like
an alcoholic out of work artist too but
now here we are
the world is back rotating in its normal
axis so here we go
[Music]
so spider-man came out the year was
2002. actually a year before that there
we go story time not gonna
don't want to bore you too much but it's
a fun story for me
anyway so some of you may or may not
know i was a projectionist
back in the day and the year 2001 was
one of the years i was a projectionist
and this was about july
2001 i don't remember what movie
this trailer came on it was either
jurassic park 3
or the 2001 tim burton planet of the
apes movie i don't remember which point
is
new movie came in in the metal cans as
they would they would come in
six little reels that i would have to
then splice into one big reel
some movies were five reels some were
nine six being the average but the cool
thing was when a new movie came in there
would be
new trailers in those cans it was neat
because there was no
social media you know you didn't get
advanced
notice there were still there were
surprises in the movie trailer world and
on this particular day sometime in july
2001 one of those surprises was a
trailer that said
spider-man and my brain just about
melted
right before or after i just about [ __ ]
myself the trailer had to actually
end up being pulled because it has the
twin towers in it and a couple months
later 911 happened but in that time i
would go into the auditorium every time
that trailer showed i knew the movies it
was on
and i would go right in there and this
one dude because the trailer is
actually set up to where you don't know
that it's a spider-man trailer it's just
a bank robbery going down and
like i said just there's no social media
back then so no one knew what this
trailer was it was just a bank robbery
happening and when the helicopter gets
caught
and it zooms out and it's a spider web
and the propeller is kind of twitching
like it's a
fly in a spider web this one dude in one
of the auditoriums just some customer
and he goes
oh my god it's [ __ ] spider-man which
was
that's the perfect response to this
trailer it's actually the trailers on
youtube
i'll put a link below go check it out
and watch it with the context that when
you
watch this trailer you know a spider-man
movie is coming out next year
but nowhere in your realm of reality is
this trailer going to
just be here on this movie whatever
movie you're watching
in july 2001 and even as you watch this
trailer watch it
knowing that you don't know it's a
spider-man trailer until you know it's a
spider-man trailer in that context
it's one of the best caesar trailers
ever made i think i mean well don't go
yet
you know watch this video then after
this video go watch that trailer sorry
to pratt along with that story but you
know
it's all part of my sam raimi spider-man
experience as it was rolling out back in
the day because for a while
just kind of looked like this movie
wasn't gonna happen there was some
production hell
james cameron was gonna do it for a bit
and then he wasn't we're all very
connected to the goings-on
of movies now but back when back in the
late 90s early 2000s the internet was
just a different place we all had to
scramble the barnes and noble and flip
through whatever movie magazine to try
to find some tidbit about the spider-man
movie and
well i kept up on it i was pumped for it
and so when i saw this trailer i was
like oh my god it's like it's reality
and it'll happen
and then it came out and it was awesome
and when it came out when it hit it was
the highest grossing
opening weekend of any movie ever when
it came out which its number now seems
pretty modest but back then it was crazy
because what sam raimi did in this movie
is he nailed the tone of spider-man
there are things that he
changed in this movie i was like
logistically i don't like that he did
that but as the movie went on i just i
stopped
caring like he doesn't make web shooters
it's just actually a thing
that he shoots webs out of his wrist
which is funny because if they're
actually making it towards like oh he
has spider powers he can make webbing
like a spider he would kind of shoot it
out of his ass i'm just saying
which i was bummed out that they didn't
show how smart peter parker actually is
that's something the later spider-man
franchises were like all right we do
want to emphasize that and i appreciate
that well
i mean the movie says he's smart but
other than saying that he is smart he
doesn't
really do anything with that intellect
but what this movie really does for the
most part nail is the tone
that 90s spider-man tone is absolutely
100 percent here sometimes it works
perfectly sometimes you're like
i'm like you see that it's 90s g's
that's for sure man when he's committing
he's committing but i suppose the good
part is the cheese in this movie never
compromises the enjoyment of the
adventure there is that no there is
actually a superhero adventure
character story he is telling in this
movie let's talk about the action this
movie
it just set comic book movies up to be
like okay you have to be this
exciting now some of the cgi is a little
dated now sure but in terms of adventure
this was next level live-action
spider-man though he is cgi spider-man
swinging through the streets of new york
i had never experienced anything like it
and as much as i want to be oh mr
objective movie guy i'd i can't help but
watch this movie now and get transported
back to that time funny enough he
doesn't actually get a spider-man suit
until about an hour into the movie which
is one of the complaints
in the andrew garfield amazing
spider-man movie but i think the reason
this movie didn't warrant that many
complaints well
first of all that social media was not a
thing when this movie came out but also
it sets up the peter parker harry
osborne
mary jane whole friendship triangle
thing it sets it up very well that's a
complaint a lot of people have is like
mary jane in this movie's just kind of
the girlfriend the damsel and that's her
role and you're not wrong i will say a
thing that does
work with that in this movie is when the
green goblin takes mary jane and
i was like are they gonna do the gwen
stacy thing in here i thought she might
actually get her neck snapped at a point
i thought spider-man was gonna web her
foot and maybe break her neck and
i didn't know so at least it has that
tension going for it i didn't know what
to expect and from there we transitioned
to talking about the casting toby
mcguire as
peter parker slash spider-man some of
his dialogue's a little clunky
like someone was like hey that's how
spider-man talks in the comic books so
maybe it'll translate perfectly to film
it doesn't always translate perfectly to
film
well it's taken the subway don't mind us
you just need to use the elevator
that's not his fault that's a
screenwriting thing it's in the script i
know toby gets some [ __ ] from spidey
purists out there but in the end
i've always enjoyed the guy as
spider-man i mean he was spider-man for
an entire generation a generation who
loves spider-man i think the dude was
solid but if you want to talk about
perfection willem dafoe is norman
osborne
holy [ __ ] it's like he was born to play
this although his goblin suits
i was never a huge fan of it what it's
like you know at the movie theater we
got these promo things i think they were
pins
and it was the best look at the goblin i
got and that was the point where i was
like every shot of the green goblin in
this movie
his mouth is open he's making the same
facial expression oh god it's gonna be a
helmet he's not gonna move his mouth is
he i don't like that thought
which one of the other projections was
like i'm sure they'll make it look good
i'm sure it'll be fine and
it was pretty much what i was afraid of
which everything on paper though it's
great like his motivation him being the
green goblin everything he does he
starts
wiping out his competition it it all
works as the green goblin it's a great
first spider-man
villain it's a great villain to have him
be like i was just kind of
montaging saving people and they're just
stopping small crime not gonna take out
this [ __ ] this is next level
[ __ ] it's all right i guess i'm the
only one who can and he's actually
wrapped up with his personal life it's
just it's a perfect first spider-man
villain i suppose the green goblin in
spider-man
is proof positive that if you have a
cosmetic gripe about a character's
outfit it's just a cosmetic gripe as
long as the character's still written
like the character
acts like the character the motivation
is on point for the character
and the actor sells it and pulls it off
and all of which is true
he even starts [ __ ] with peter
parker's personal life i think that's
amazing
and everything about willem dafoe in the
suit as the goblin out of the suit is
norman osborne right down to that goblin
laugh
it all just sells it so yeah could have
had a cooler suit but the goblin still
rocks
my favorite parts of the goblin is when
willem dafoe's playing norman osborne
talking to the green goblin he's talking
to the mask or he's talking to the
mirror point is
those scenes are my favorite goblin
scenes everything else just kind of
works to be like all right now he's
gonna fight spider-man though that one
scene where he captures spider-man
and he tells them about no matter how
much you've done for them eventually
they will hate you
rings true that's just the nature of
people and i've always appreciated that
scene
and it hasn't been proven wrong thus far
i think people would eventually hate
spider-man if you were real and that's
where the devil's in the details that's
where this movie shines like that scene
where spider-man needs to go into this
burning building and this cops like
you're under arrest
and you hear a lady screaming though
it's the goblin but no one else knows
that and
he's like i'm going and then the cop
lets him go he's like i'll be here when
you get back he's like i ain't coming
back and the cop just has to let
spiderman go
and i like those moments are awesome
they're wonderful superhero moments that
i just
love and the other casting from the gods
themselves jk simmons is j jonah jameson
jonah jameson i was like i don't know
who can do that perfectly i don't know
tom scared because it kind of looked
like him but he didn't have that energy
then this jk simmons guy all right we'll
see what he has oh my god he's perfect
so perfect in fact he's
no spoilers never mind and even then he
made jay jonah jameson something
else you know he made it his own i knew
jay jonah jameson he was this
loud angry person who hated spider-man
but jk
simmons just brought that fast-talking
nature to where oh yeah he was loud and
angry but he was also
fast talking and hilarious you bring me
some more shots of that newspaper
selling clown maybe i'll take him off
your hands
but i never said you have a job meat
i'll send you a nice box of christmas
meat best i can do get out of here
but he didn't overcook the comedy he was
just amazing
and also important character moment that
moment where the goblin has him and he's
like who brings the pictures of
spider-man he's like i don't know his
stuff comes in the mail it shows that he
actually does care about peter parker he
cares about the people that work for him
and that's another
spidey element for me that i get here in
these rainy movies
that i don't get in the other movies
it's the daily bugle you know jay jonah
jameson
robbie robertson betty branst you know
the whole crew that works there
there was actually an easter egg in here
where i was like oh my god is that it
was
when robbie robertson's like eddie's
been on it for weeks we can't get a good
picture spider-man i'm like he's talking
about eddie
they're gonna bring venom it's gonna be
so awesome
and i cannot leave this video without
talking about the danny elfman score
that spider-man
theme it's up there with batman and
superman's theme like i think batman i
think
i think of the danny elfman score
superman but you know the john williams
score
so classic but so is danny elfman's
spider-man score like when the beginning
credits first came on
like this is instant classic superhero
score
and that last shot of him swinging
through new york when he's like who am i
i'm spider-man
boom score comes on spider-man is just
going through new york with all the cgi
that blew my mind back in 2002 that's
such a great closing scene for
a superhero movie and a spider-man movie
and the musical scored by danny elfman
it perfectly parallels what sam raimi's
spider-man was doing you know it doesn't
try to be superman doesn't try to be the
batman theme
just like sam raimi spider-man doesn't
try to be superman or batman it tried to
be spider-man but i legit love this
movie even with some of the dated cgi
whether it be some of that or some of
that early 2000s
even throwing back to 90s comic book
cheese none of it compromises the fact
that when you're watching this movie
with peter parker and
he grows to be spider-man that
coming-of-age story and then he has to
step up and take out the green goblin
who's his friend's dad
all of it was what i wanted to see in a
spider-man movie and nothing not the
sands of time or the evolution of comic
book movies compromises that feeling
that's what i mean when i say this is
just
the spider-man movie for the 90s
spider-man fan in me that perfectly sets
up the tension between
spider-man and harry osborne and peter
parker
mary jane like all of it is set up going
forward to this trilogy we all knew we
would get and it's so
clear as to where they're going the
vision is so there like
all of us like i knew after walking out
of the first movie that okay in the
third movie harry's going to be
the new goblin because that's what
happened in the comic books and they set
it up to do that it won't be in the next
movie
there will be some tension there but in
the third movie that's when it'll happen
they were going there they kind of did
it yes i suppose i just appreciate the
fact that they were clear in their
vision they showed the audience where
their vision is going
they stuck the landing for this
adventure but also set it up
to be a trilogy of its own adventure
they're actually gonna do a four
which then never happened i loved
spider-man before
sam raimi's spider-man but sam raimi's
spider-man was the movie i now
had to where i could easily show people
hey this is why i love spider-man it was
the first time i had that i could be
like look mom
this is why this is why i didn't get
chicks in high school
worth it right yeah
sure was whatever flaws this movie has
it doesn't change the fact that for me
sam raimi's spider-man remains awesome
tacular
[Music]
there you go sam raimi's spider-man
spider-man 2 he'll eventually do that
look i'm kind of on a roll now just let
it happen
it'll happen they only made one sequel
right sure
i haven't sat down to watch three in its
entirety
since the movie theater so who knows
maybe i'll love it times change people
change
it's possible just don't remember loving
that
one i mean i've dabbled it's been on tv
and i've been like all right yeah sure
well i'm doing other stuff but i haven't
engaged from beginning to end since the
movie theater anyhow
spider-man have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you